this is a production of cornell
university
as always we'll keep it to the fastest
30 minutes in trip some of us
aren't all 30 minutes 30 minutes and to
that i would say
there are disruptions in the space-time
continuum because this show is so
engaging and interesting
uh so we'll get right on with it today
this is gonna be episode 12 of the
cornell turk show series this year
uh our guest today dr matt elmore from
rutgers university
excited to have matt on today to talk
about some spring weed issues that's
always a topic of conversation
um so we'll get to that uh with matt in
a little bit uh but as always we'll
start off with uh kind of a weekly
review and update for frank frank it's
snowing here i don't know if you have
anything to make us
feel better up uh up here in upstate new
york
you know i'm showing you a picture of a
cemetery i don't know if that makes you
but it's certainly where i got to get
out and about into the greenwood
cemetery in brooklyn this week
and you're looking at one of our
research plots there that's
investigating
using different mixes uh for the
cemetery and this happens to be
a uh sort of old-fashioned horse pasture
mix
that we made with john scy on long
island from all pro horticulture and
actually
over the last couple of years has been
looking uh pretty good so we're starting
out with something a little bit
funny today carl um with the cemetery
it's not the most uplifting it is
it is snowing but it also is national
lawn care month so
i think it's good to uh remind people
beyond just how they look
uh as to what you know how long sort of
involved this is our grounds week and
i've decided
that carl i'm going to wade right into
this brother i'm going to get myself in
a whole bunch of trouble in the next
several minutes trying to
wade my way through what this is and
what this obsession
is with banning blowers and our industry
using blowers particularly in the
grounds area this is an example of a ban
in place uh outside the fall window
right they'll let you do it
uh for cleanup in the spring uh and then
uh for leaf drop in the fall but they
want these things
uh shut down uh during the non-fall
period so i
i poked around a little bit looking for
this uh
information a little bit about this and
of course this is a
big time of it being used and honestly
i've talked to a lot of my
extension colleagues in the region and
many of them have noticed and they
stepped outside the cacophony
of blowers that seemed to dominate the
sound of the landscape and it's good no
people are working you know this is all
good from uh
it's legal to do all those things are
good uh but i pulled something
from an article from facilities net and
then from another article that was
looking at
palm springs uh in particular and
so first off uh people make the
objection that there's uh
you know for one hour they equal a car
uh driving for eight hours
right they're blowing they're blowing
dust uh all over the place right
okay so they're blowing so so you got
carbon monoxide
you got dust uh it's blowing air of
quite a bit of air around uh they're
noisy uh and and it's bad for your
ears so obviously your your operators
are gonna wanna wear some hearing
protection
uh in palm springs i'll get back to this
comment in a second
in palm springs uh when they put the ban
into effect one out of four calls
into the code enforcement office were
reporting leaf blower violations now of
course you know
life's kind of tough in palm springs i
imagine for some folks so
calling into the code enforcement
officer was one thing but it just felt
like these things are not effective
most guys are just scouting the you know
sprouting the rules in some of these
places now
you know you know i'm not a big fan of
more regulation unless it's really well
thought out
um and so here are these two legislators
commenting in new york
uh this is about the ban going on
that they're being proposed in new york
these are two legislators
in the bronx one of them is from the
bronx much of this work done by leaf
power is often unnecessary
okay let's talk a little bit about that
it can be done by
environmentally friendly tools i'd like
them to discuss
what those are oh a mulching mower well
how does a mulching mower
uh get the stuff off the sidewalk so
you know i feel like you know everybody
laughs like oh
national lawn care month oh isn't that
sweet oh that sounded stupid
well why should we promote these things
and then when you you know you realize
you're dealing a lot of times with
people who make rules
who simply don't understand the nature
of the work
or are listening to you know one
side of the story and i don't think
anybody that uses blowers like
pesticides and other sorts of things
wants to hurt the environment wants to
blow dust around at a loud uh
sound that hurts everybody's ears i
think that
it's good to sort of force innovation
sometimes
but these bands are really putting a
significant burden
on the landscape operator so i know this
has nothing to do with the conversation
about weeds today
but i thought i would rant a little bit
about it because we hear
from a lot of people about this on a
pretty regular basis now listen carl i'm
going to transition to your tip here
and just say well maybe you're the kind
of person that does this to their front
law and this is some work we're
currently doing with bill miller uh our
greenhouse professor working with the
dutch bulb industry here at cornell
and and uh while he's been looking at
sort of putting these things into the
landscape to
sort of make the landscape look pretty
i'm much more interested in using these
tools
these flowers as tools for reducing
mowing in the spring
maybe i can cut back on a few mowings
how long can we go
before we have to mow these things for
them to maintain their perenniality
right so bill's starting to ask these
questions we've got them planted in
different grasses looking at growth
rates
and so we're trying to get a better idea
my idea is hey maybe i can save some
some mowing in the springtime i'm not a
fan of these rows that bill likes
i like the meadowed planting approach
here
where we just spread them out into the
lawn so we'll we'll give you pictures of
this as we progress
now listen carl i bet a lot of people
are looking down at the ground in the
spring after they blow everything away
and they got a lot of bare ground
so what are your thoughts about this as
a tip for the day
yes so you know today's topic obviously
we'll be focusing on weed control but
um you know you know one of the first
things we always talk about when it
comes to weed control is the best way to
keep weeds out
is to have a dense stand of turf and
when you see
this despair ground early in the spring
what i think i'm staring
out at my yard right now where my dog
runs around and tears the place up
is uh why don't we just throw some seed
out there and use seed the newest latest
varieties
we have malmoron today from rutgers
which of course the breeding program at
rutgers produces
so much great new genetics so our tip of
the day today
a great quote from betsy lane under
seeding is overrated
meaning uh you know it's it's overrated
not to throw seed out there and i think
you know sometimes maybe we overlook
seed maybe it's too simple it's too
obvious but
um you know again introducing seed not
just once during the year but repetitive
overseeding we've seen this on athletic
fields with our sports folks
uh talking about routine traffic and
then using seed
to keep that dense standard turf uh
really again
under seeding is overrated let's get
some more seed out there
and uh and create a dense standard turf
to keep weeds out and i think some of it
carl is you know
lawns are considered perennial crops
right it's like wait a minute
what do i got to keep seeing the darn
thing for does it just keep coming up
back from the ground or
isn't there something underneath the
soil that it grows from i think there's
this
misconception that somewhat because it's
a perennial plant
that maybe it doesn't require uh regular
over
seeding now as we think about
overseeding and getting grass to grow
obviously soil temperature is a big
driver of this
and you can see in just a couple of days
the soil is starting to warm now
up into the hudson valley certainly warm
enough down where matt is in
in north central jersey uh you know
where
uh you can get pretty good germination
especially on a bright sunny day
uh where the soil might be bare it'll
warm up pretty good
early on now the thing that you have to
keep in mind is up until these last few
days
we've been well ahead of normal most of
the region
is a week to two weeks to some places
like around buffalo
three weeks ahead of normal so you know
you're talking about a growing season
that's already been well underway
soils that are now warming up but at the
same time
it looks like the rainfall is going to
make its way along the coast
we've been uh relatively dry for much of
the northeast
uh parts of the northeast of course the
the story around this show
is wherever rich buckley is matt it's
always raining a little bit
no matter when we talk to rich it's it's
raining wherever he is it's not friday
so
i gotta believe it must be raining in
jersey today somewhere so
um we know there are some areas that are
getting plenty of moisture the soil's
starting to warm
the season's getting ahead of itself um
it looks like we're going to get a
little bit of a stall now
it looks like moving forward we're not
going to see a big advancement in
temperature
we're going to sit here at normal and
normal is between mid 50s and mid 60s
now
we'll get some rainfall along the coast
and as that rainfall and cool weather
comes
over the last several years we've seen
increasing problems in lawn areas with
red thread
this is a disease oftentimes associated
historically associated with low
fertility
but as brother rich buckley tells us
fungi fungi don't read the books
and it looks like either the conditions
are becoming more conducive to this
particular
problem the grasses we're putting into
the landscape
that we might not have selected for this
particular problem might be having some
weaknesses
uh there just may be uh more pathogen
around now with the changing climate who
knows
what the reason is but i don't think
most people would deny they're not
seeing it more
uh than they used to see it so red
thread
a one we used to think we could
fertilize our way out of
we're starting to see in areas now where
even then they're well fertilized
when you get this growth early like
we've had and now it stalls and sits
there
the fungi gets established as well a lot
of like weeds they all get established
as well
and you know if it gets wet and if it
stays a little bit warm those things
might keep growing
while our grasses might not keep growing
so it's important to understand now
we're going to start seeing broadleaf
weeds
and you know we use the old midwest
growing degree day
model for dandelions and 24d uh the two
formulations of that and you can see
you know you're really early still even
out to the 22nd you can go to our
forecast website
um you know we put these maps in you can
see a singular day like today
or way out into the future that's the
wonderful part about these particular uh
maps that that uh
we give you some idea of what might be
coming now
we use the gdd tracker for the
pre-emergent stuff
uh just for timing i've always been
interested it seems
about a week or two ahead of where
germination is
i'm kind of interested in it it's saying
it's pretty late now matt
now we're going to get the questions
with you but i got to i didn't have you
on just to answer the old softball
crabgrass questions or even goose grass
questions
which i know you're doing a lot of work
on these days we're starting to get
comments from the field about
your pal here false green kailinga
on some reports of it coming in on sod
and also some japanese stilt grass matt
yeah
it reports a japanese stilt grass so i'm
going to shut up
and i'm going to you know start with
just hey
um thanks for joining us
good to see you appreciate you taking
the time
let's start with the easy stuff before i
get you to the tricky stuff
um pre-emergent crab grass control
lining it up with what carl might be
talking about with scene
how do you balance those two things in
the lawn and grounds
area right because you can't deny what
he said is right yeah let's get some
grass growing
but you also can't deny man crabgrass is
pretty nasty
the furthest off you get right so how do
you balance those things
yeah it's a good question it's it's
tricky i mean
you you do have to probably decide am i
going to put out a traditional
pre-immersion or am i going to seed
and then if you go the route of seed
then you have to
get creative with your crabgrass control
if there was a lot of crab grass in
there and you have to
potentially you know we're looking at
tenacity as an option around seating
you know or waiting for post-emergence
control with something like
drive or quinclerac but you know
tenacity doesn't have the residual of
your traditional
pre-emergence so um
yeah it's it's you have to pick one one
strategy i guess but when you
well i'm not well i'm not gonna leave
you that easy
when you use the word creative you have
to be creative with your crabgrass and
you know
the people who listen to this show matt
are the most creative professionals
you know in the industry today so i want
to
give you a chance to elaborate on that
you mentioned
quinclerac you mentioned tenacity
there's a claim
um you know i know you're toying around
with fiesta
how something like that might be in the
seed bed
does creative mean watch and then react
would you go post like we used to have
that remember that
square one herbicide that had the combo
i think they stopped making it
yeah they don't feel about choosing the
seed and then
trying to follow up with the posts yeah
so
if you've got areas that are really bare
and you know essentially you'd be
putting out a pre-emergent on bare soil
we don't want that situation right
that's not going to work um so yeah you
basically need to come up with a game
plan for those areas you're going to see
of okay what's my post-emergence
herbicide program going to be
and how am i going to work that you know
in with the seeding and essentially if
you see now you know i get a couple
mowings on that
uh on this on those uh you know
seedlings
then you can start to utilize your
post-emergence herbicides
like you know things with quinclerac or
acclaim
i mean we've been we have been doing
some work with fiesta we haven't looked
at it on seedlings
but that's probably something we need to
do um
and so yeah i think you just need to
have a game plan
and you need to be ready to make those
applications and don't wait until the
plants get too big because
then you once you get behind the eight
ball especially in a new seed bed
you know you're gonna be it's gonna be
an uphill battle so if
you know by say you seeded next week
let's say yeah
you know by may 15th end of may you
really need to make sure you're scouting
those areas
so that you can make the herbicide
application if you need it
um and then maybe you know so that would
be my strategy i guess if i'm if i'm
seeding
yeah that's good because creative also
means the ability to be responsive
right if you're running a traditional
thing where you visit and this is what
it is and that's that
you know the pre-emergent approach
certainly works there now let me move on
to the other one
that that tends to be the scourge in
most landscapes is
is now what your got me concerned about
these last couple years is goose grass
how does goose grass fit into this
starting and stopping
uh of the early season the early
applications that we have to sometimes
make uh for crabgrass and maybe even
kailinga and maybe even for still grass
i don't presume to know that yet um and
how does that
jive with boost grass pressure which can
germinate
even later right i mean it comes in
later and germinates later
how's how do you jive that with goose
grass stuff man
these pre-emergence programs yeah yeah
you you probably if goose grass is a
real problem you need to think about a
second
pre-emergence application probably or
you need to be ready with the
post-emergence herbicides and i think in
a lot of cases
you know the post-emergence herbicides
can be a good option if you don't want
to make
multiple pre-emergence applications
because i know sometimes there's concern
about that
multiple pre-emergence applications
especially on athletic fields
so it's you know the herbicide options
are a little different
and i think that's a key is that as
goose grass seems to start to move more
throughout the region you just need to
make sure you can
identify it even when it's relatively
small
differentiate it from crabgrass because
you know a real
tool in the toolbox for crab grass is
quinclerak drive and that doesn't do
anything
to goose grass it may you know um so
then you know if goose grass is a
problem you need to look maybe to
herbicides
post-emergent herbicides like acclaim
and pylex and again just trying to be
proactive
and making applications when the plants
are small
is going to be a big help to use less
pesticide
and so but you know the big thing with
both of these weeds is
is kind of going back to what carl said
is really you know the herbicide is a
good tool but
you got to think about creating turf
competition and especially with goose
grass it seems like it
really does not do well if there's good
turf competition
um so you know anything you can do right
now to actually get out in front of that
goose grass
get some turf competition i think we'll
pay dividends later in the summer in
terms of reduced
herbicide applications reduced goose
grass pressure but it is becoming you
know more of a problem
i don't think we have to worry about
goose grass emergence yet
soil temps are still cool and we're not
getting now sometimes this time of year
we get those wild temperature swings
where we get a few 80 degree days and
then it cools back down we've kind of
just been steadily
warming it seems this year so um
you know things are we're starting to
see crab grass emergence
and and i think we're a ways away from
goose grass but yeah
i think and the kind of i know i'm kind
of going off here but
with goose grass i think the thing to be
concerned about too
is uh if we get weather late in the
season
that you know wet conditions late in the
summer we get
you know diseases that come in and thin
out the turf that's i think
where goose grass really gets a foothold
is you get pythium you get gray leaf
spot you get
flooding um that's where it seems like
if we get that those weather conditions
in august that
that you know you really actually can
get some goose grass
coming in well i just love that you've
got to beat on goose grass because i
think that's the way we have to be
with these issues we got to be out ahead
of it seeing it coming
and knowing how to adapt and adjust
because it's not just you use different
products
you have to approach a post-emergent
strategy differently than you approach a
pre-emergent strategy no matter
no matter what they are so let's get to
how do you like the uh
have you found any value in these spring
dandelion models for really being good
times
for these apps have you ever played
around with that and what is your
thought about spring broadleaf weed
control in general
recognizing its post-emerge yeah i
haven't we haven't done any really work
here looking at different timings
um there yeah i think the growing degree
day models that are out there are pretty
good
um and i think the key is just make sure
that
the weeds are actively growing and i
think avoiding sometimes that peak
flowering period can help too even
though that's when they're most obvious
yeah so um yeah we haven't done a lot
there i mean
you know the products are are pretty
good
yeah yeah yeah don't need to go anymore
i just wanted to throw it in there
because we use
that model and a lot of people like
spring wheat
spring control because that's when you
see them but of course we know the best
time to do it is in the latter part of
the season
for deeper longer lasting kill than you
would get in the spring which in my
opinion sometimes amounts to a burn on
bigger plants
that wind up needing a treatment again
in the fall anyway
is that consistent with your thinking
yeah yeah i agree
um and i think the model is good because
it helps prevent you know too early of
an application when things are maybe too
cool
so um all right so listen let's get to
the real tough ones now
okay you know you've been playing around
with full screen kylinga you're
let's explain this to everybody uh right
away because it's different than
green kailinga yeah it is a warm season
plant likely closer to a sedge
uh than a grass right it's in the center
i believe it is
so yeah i mean it's a perennial so
there's a lot of similarities between it
and yellow nuts edge
um there's some time control in these
days
yeah and yeah nutsedge is a challenge i
think it always will be
there's some new you know some of the
new stuff coming out of i saw from
nebraska and other stuff it seems like
you know something i want to follow up
on is
early season applications for nutsedge
control you know we always talk about
well you know
make those applications by mid-june
before the longest day of the year
before you start to get a lot of tuber
production
there's some stuff that you know
suggests that maybe making an
application
in may or late may you know shortly
after emergence
might might help so um i'd say it's a
little bit experimental for now but
that's kind of what i got my eye on in
terms of well maybe we need to start
making these applications earlier
because those plants can actually start
to produce tubers the nutsedge that is
four to six weeks after they
merge i don't know um so especially in
bare soil areas you know we're not too
far away from seeing those first
nutsedge plants come out of the ground
in this area um what about the kyling
what about the fall
linga because it seems like the people
who have this
big problem yeah yeah yeah it really can
come in and take over an area because it
you know nutsedge mixes well with the
turf you could say the kalinga just
tends to choke it out in dense mats
so it's a perennial as well it doesn't
have tubers but it has
rhizomes that really stay pretty close
to the surface so
uh you know sometimes a sod cutter is a
good way to get rid of it
but obviously very laborious so maybe
not
an option in all situations um there's
there's herbicide options and really i
think
in serious infestations combining that
herbicide with some sort of seeding
operation is good um
and so you know there's
the herbicides that we've found success
with are things like the halo sulfuron
um and the uh amazosulfuron as well the
solero has been really effective
uh sulfentrazone is another option uh
very effective especially if you can get
to the higher you know end of that rate
range on the label get to six or eight
ounces per acre
right that's it not all of those are
labeled in new york
that's yeah that's a good point yeah
this whole venture zone
and the solero sorry the celero is not
labeled new york
okay so so that's very interesting now
listen here's the thing
again i'm as interested in the sort of
strategy with this plant than i am
necessarily the products because these
sort of difficult to control weeds
you got to find the time to exploit when
they're at their weakest or when you're
whatever you spray is going to give you
the most bang for your buck
yeah who's the timing for this team yeah
good question so really
um early early spring um
well before the calendar technically
turns to summer
sorry late spring you know we're looking
late may
to mid-june after you get some emergence
but we have
you know evaluated these things in
mid-summer and they don't work as well
so it is a spring you know kind of
application
or you can wait until the fall and
sometimes i've been
recommending that because if you've got
a situation where your entire
property is kalinga well then you're
going to kill that off before we go into
the hot part of the year so we might
want to keep that green cover
during the summer so another option is
to spray these things in
late august and then do a seating about
a month later
um and that that has been working pretty
well in some of our research so
the key is that you need to to make the
application three to four weeks before
you seed um because they're toxic
you know they're gonna they'll injure
young seedlings if you spray them and
then seed to the same week
all right listen we're getting close to
wrapping up i want to ask you about
steelgrass i've heard randy prostak our
brother up in
yeah say it's a shade
tolerant warm season grass something you
don't see very often
um what are your thoughts about uh the
status of this problem in lawns that you
are aware of and
some some simple strategies for
controlling
yeah it's getting a lot worse and what i
have
seen is it seems like there's biotypes
that are actually have moved out of the
understory of the forest where we don't
mow and they have adapted to this
frequent mowing environment which is
a little little concerning yeah
um and the other challenge is that it's
you know it's finding a niche where
it germinates before we've put out our
crabgrass pre-immersion
so it you know it that's another reason
it's kind of spreading i think just like
goose grass has found a way to evade our
typical
pre-emergence program so has the stilt
grass so yeah it's gonna get worse it's
a challenge
um it's good you know good if you're in
the weeds business
i guess uh but well let's not gloat
let's at least give them something they
could spray on it
yeah so a claim is the only post
emergence option
registered for post emergence control
and the key is to get out you know know
where it was the previous year and make
the applications relatively early in the
spring because once it starts to get
big it's you know you're not going to be
able to control it so typically i get
you know a lot of phone calls in july
and august by then it's too late so try
to go in those areas and look for it
right now actually it's already
germinated for most of us probably
um we're getting close to it so look
where areas where it was problematic in
the past if you see seedlings now
that means you've got a problem and you
can make acclaim
applications uh right now at relatively
low rates and still get good control so
it's because it's not a
you know you can save yourself some
money and not go with that full
you know full rate you can go you can
look at the label and it recommends
lower rates for smaller plants
there you go carl a pro tip as matt
wraps up
any questions for him uh from the from
the audience or maybe a comment for you
yeah no questions from the audience but
you know i think one of the
themes i hear today from you guys
talking is is the need to be kind of
proactive especially if you're
adopting this post strategy where maybe
you're using seed and a post-emergent
control strategy if i'm a landscaper and
i've got a bunch different properties
matt have you seen examples of of those
sorts of people being successful they've
got
100 200 300 properties have you seen
examples where they can be proactive on
a bunch of different properties
um as opposed to kind of a blanket
pre-treatment program
and uh have they have you seen examples
of them being flexible in that kind of
program yeah great question i've i've
had a couple calls with some
large lawn care companies and they are
getting into
site-specific management in a lot of
cases that's both within the property
and then within different properties so
i think
you know there's it's a lot of just how
do you manage the
the um the data that you have and your
your applications and then adapting some
sort of spray technology that's going to
allow you to be
you know some sort of application
technology that's going to allow you to
to switch it up between properties so
there are people doing it
and it's good to hear because you know
as we start to see more weeds
more weeds adapting to our management
strategies we're going to need to be
flexible
on a large scale so great answer matt
thanks so much for taking the time to
join us today yeah it's great to see you
guys
so great yeah thanks for hosting us
let's go let's get out of here
yep uh as always we're here right on the
nail 30 minutes uh
thanks everyone our live attendees if
you're listening on
podcast or youtube uh we'll be back
again next thursday for our 13th show
this year if you've got any questions
reach out to us
twitter email me if you've got questions
for our guests
we're always happy to answer those on
the show for me
carl my account got hacked and i'm
permanently suspended
twitter world getting kicked off twitter
world but uh
we'll see we'll see everybody hopefully
no more hacks and
twitter accounts matt thanks again see
everybody guys
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu